die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem freitag über die sportlichen
erfolge berichtet norbert lehmann und
sachvermögen und das sind unsere themen
von heute
tausende tote fische und viele fragen in
der oder gibt einen massensterben rätsel
auf proben deuten auf eine
quecksilbervergiftung hin
entspannung aber keine entwarnung
gesundheitsminister lauterbach fürchtet
nach dem abklingen der korona sommer
welle neue probleme im herbst
und auf die bahnrad frauen ist verlass
das deutsche team holte zweimal gold bei
den european championships in münchen
bitte warten sie nicht in der oder und
vermeiden sie kontakt mit flusswasser so
warnen die behörden in brandenburg in
der oder wurde quecksilber nachgewiesen
das könnte eine erklärung sein für das
massenhafte fischsterben
möglicherweise ist es aber auch eine
kombination aus niedrigwasser hitze und
giftstoffen tote fische fanden sich vor
allem in der gegend bei frankfurt wo die
ohne der grenzfluss zwischen deutschland
und polen ist auf polnischer seite
wusste man da schon seit zwei wochen von
dem fischsterben behörden bei breslau
hatten unregelmäßigkeiten festgestellt
den deutschen aber nicht bescheid
gegeben in pakistan hat details
es sind diese bilder die für entsetzen
sorgen bei anwohnern helfern und
fischern seit dienstag holen sie in den
landkreisen entlang der oder verendete
tiere aus dem wasser erste proben
zeigten einen hohen quecksilber wert
doch es ist nicht sicher ob das zum tod
der fische geführt hat
die eingesperrt worden sind ist
ein toxischer stoff soll die oder
durchlaufen haben eine fabrik nahe
breslau steht unter verdacht doch
beweise gibt es nicht
funktionale politik polizei und natur
inspektoren werden alle fabriken an der
oder kontrollieren die potenzielle
umweltsünder sein könnten
bereits vor zwei wochen hat das
fischsterben polen begonnen
ministerpräsident morawietz gehe davon
aus dass emi abfälle in den fluss
gekippt wurden die regierung verspricht
aufklärung die vermisst die deutsche
seite seit tagen kritisiert polnische
behörden selbstverständlich müssen wir
davon ausgehen dass wir auch
ordnungsgemäß informiert werden aber da
gab es eben ein versagen an einer stelle
wo informationen weitergeleitet wurden
nicht in den internationalen bereich
also nicht nach deutschland
weitergegeben wurden sondern in polen
auf polnischer seite zurückgehalten
wurden nun will auch polen
untersuchungsergebnisse liefern
allerdings nicht vor sonntagabend die
notwendigen fischproben sind noch immer
nicht in dem zuständigen labor
angekommen von einer naturkatastrophe
sprechen die menschen überall an der
oder zwar kann bisher niemand den
schaden für die umwelt abschätzen aber
dass es ihn gibt ist unübersehbar
jan meyer ist für uns an der oderbrücke
in schwedt wie gefährlich ist das im
moment
dass das wasser der oder vergiftet es
wurde hier in schwedt und am
nationalpark unteres odertal hinter mir
gestern bemerkt seitdem sieht man
niemand mehr baden oder angeln
quecksilber ist hochgefährlich für die
menschen die behörden mussten das noch
nicht einmal ausdrücklich verbieten das
einzige was man jetzt tun kann ist die
fischkadaver aus der oder zu holen damit
das gift nicht weiter in den
naturkreislauf gelangt dafür haben sich
freiwillige auch morgen wieder
verabredet in verschiedenen gemeinden
hier entlang der oder gab es sowas schon
mal
in den vergangenen jahrzehnten besonders
zu ddr-zeiten gab kam es immer wieder
vor dass das vergiftete fisch das
vergiftete plus wasser fische auch in
großen mengen tötete die fischer hier
berichten uns da das allerdings immer
wieder passierte dass fische in
nebengewässern überlebten und sich so
die bestände dann auch regelmäßig
reaktivierten das hofft man auch in
diesem mal dieses mal aber ob es
wirklich so weit kommt ist ungewiss die
kombination aus hitze die durch wasser
und verschiedenen giftstoffen die lässt
schlimmes befürchten
danke für diese informationen aus
brandenburg herrn meier war dass
das wasser in der oder ist extrem
niedrig genau wie am rhein bei coop im
mittelrheintal beträgt die tiefe der
fahrrinne nur noch ein meter 54
die folge frachtschiffe können nur noch
mit sehr wenig ladung fahren gilt als
nadelöhr für die gesamte rhein
schifffahrt sollte der wasserstand hier
wie erwartet weiter fallen könnte der
frachtverkehr zum erliegen kommen er
wäre dann nicht mehr rentabel zu
corona spricht gesundheitsminister
lauterbach von einem grund zur freude
der höhepunkt der sommer welle scheint
überschritten seit einigen wochen geht
die zahl der neuinfektionen deutlich
zurück die aktuelle welle ist auf dem
papier kleiner als die vorherige
ähnliches zeigt sich auf den
intensivstationen
doch die dunkelziffer es laut
gesundheitsminister hoch und steigt
sogar noch mehr von astrid randerath
kaum von corona genießen alte in die
bundespressekonferenz karl lauterbach
verteidigt das geplante
infektionsschutzgesetz die korona sommer
welle gehe gerade zurück das ist
trotzdem kein grund für eine entwarnung
denn die modellierung die es gibt und
auch also die dynamik kp auf unfälle
lassen erwarten dass im herbst werden
wieder mehr aufenthalt in innenräumen
stattfindet und auch die schule wieder
begonnen hat dass wir dann wieder stark
steigende fallzahlen erwarten müssen
hinzu kommt es gebe eine hohe
dunkelziffer so der minister das rkw
verzeichne einen besonders hohen anteil
von positiven pcr tests und vermutet
viele unerkannte infektionen der
angepasste impfstoff gegen die neue
nikon varianten soll im september bereit
stehen für die frisch geimpften gebe es
ausnahmen innerhalb der ersten drei
monate
es ist die dauer wo wir glauben dass die
neuen impfungen auch vor ansteckung
schützen
also nicht nur verschwörung verlauf
sondern auch franz steht der frisch
geimpft ist kann sich von der geplanten
regelung der masken pflicht in
innenräumen befreien auch wer ein
negatives testergebnis hat die
kontrollen soll wieder die gastronomie
übernehmen
die folge der ganzen zugangsregelungen
und auflagen war allerdings dass die
betriebe 30 prozent im durchschnitt an
umsatzverlusten hatten und zwar bis in
den märz hinein und das darf sich nicht
wiederholen das geplante gesetz geht
noch ins kabinett mit streit auf weiter
gerechnet werden
seit monaten gibt es zweifel am mali
einsatz der bundeswehr nun hat ihnen das
verteidigungsministerium vorerst
ausgesetzt in dem westafrikanischen land
sind im rahmen einer un mission rund
1000 soldatinnen und soldaten
stationiert es ist der derzeit größte
auslandseinsatz der bundeswehr und der
gefährlichste denn die lage gilt als
äußerst instabil hinzu kommen jetzt
unstimmigkeiten mit der militärregierung
instanz
aufklärung das war bislang die aufgabe
der deutschen im rahmen der un-mission
minustah in mali damit ist nun erstmal
schluss wiederholt hatte die malische
regierung den internationalen partnern
den einsatz erschwert heute wurden
erneut überflugrechte verwehrt obwohl
der manische verteidigungsminister
kamera erst gestern genau das
zugesichert hatte die taten kameras
sprechen eine andere sprache als seine
worte daher müssen wir maßnahmen
ergreifen und stellen die operation in
unserer aufklärungskräfte und die
transportflüge mit der ch 53 bis auf
weiteres ein ein signal an die hunte mit
praktischem hintergrund rund 140
soldaten aus deutschland können nicht
einreisen sie sollten die abziehenden
franzosen ersetzen und den flughafen
sichern
molly nicht befriedet terror gebiet
militäroffizier sie mixa putschte sich
an die macht er stellt sich gegen den
westen russland sieht er als partner
sollten hat er berüchtigten gruppe
wagner holte runter ins land erst diese
woche liefert russland waffen und
flugzeuge der vorwurf der größten
deutschen oppositionspartei ministerin
lamprecht habe schlecht verhandelt den
einsatz in mali gelte es zu bewahren
ohne deutsches engagement kann die
mission überhaupt nicht fortgesetzt
werden wenn das passiert werden die
konflikte innerhalb marlies und in der
gesamten region wieder aufflammen mehr
terrorismus mehr flugbewegungen in
richtung europa all das können wir nicht
wollen ampelkoalition und union wollen
eigentlich an dem einsatz festhalten
doch die frage ist wie lange er trägt
berlin noch die schikanen der malischen
regierung das vorläufige aussetzen des
einsatzes ist der beginn vom ende des
mandats es heißt die luftwaffe stehe
bereit die deutschen soldaten aus mali
zurückzuholen der heutige tag macht
endgültig klar die westlichen nationen
sind unerwünscht in mali
das gab es noch nie ein altkanzler klagt
gegen den deutschen bundestag gerhard
schröder will die sonderrechte zurück
die ihm im mai entzogen worden waren
seien staatlich finanziertes büro
inklusive mitarbeitern der
haushaltsausschuss hatte den schritt
damit begründet
schröder keine verpflichtungen aus dem
amt als ehemaliger bundeskanzler
wahrnehmen zuletzt war er wegen seiner
nähe zum russischen präsidenten putin in
die kritik geraten
kommen wir zur aktuellen regierung und
dem neuen politbarometer matthias
fornoff guten abend so gut der
bundeskanzler hat gerade wieder betont
dass niemand in der krise allein
gelassen werde wie ist die resonanz
fühlen sich die befragten angemessen
unterstützt naja die bundesregierung die
müsste schon mehr tun um die bürger zu
entlasten das finden jedenfalls die
meisten nur fünf prozent sagen es wird
zu viel getan 30 prozent finden das maß
gerade richtig und eine mehrheit von 58
prozent sagt die bundesregierung tut zu
wenig mehrheitlich sehen dass die
anhänger aller parteien so vor allem die
der linken und der afd
angesichts der energiekrise werden die
rufe nach atomkraft immer lauter wir
werden das die befragten oder längere
laufzeiten der akw es sind jedenfalls
kein tabu um die energieversorgung zu
sichern
die erneuerbaren energien sollen
schneller ausgebaut werden das wollen 93
prozent 65 prozent sind dafür atomkraft
länger zu nutzen und 61 prozent sagen
kohle kraftwerke sollen länger laufen
die hohen energiepreise haben auch mit
der unterstützung der ukraine zu tun
sollte die fortgesetzt werden
ja sagt eine stabile mehrheit von 71
prozent nur die anhänger der linken und
vor allem der afd sind mehrheitlich
dagegen die ukraine weiter zu
unterstützen
dankeschön matthias alle zahlen aus dem
politbarometer gibt es nachher im
heute-journal ab 22 uhr oder jederzeit
auf heute.de
vor dem un-sicherheitsrat haben sich
russland und die ukraine gegenseitig
vorgeworfen für den beschuss am
atomkraftwerk sapori china
verantwortlich zu sein und damit eine
nukleare katastrophe zu riskieren die
internationale atomenergie behörde sieht
derzeit zwar keine unmittelbare
bedrohung das könne sich aber jederzeit
ändern
seit tagen kommt es immer wieder zu
angriffen auf das von russland
kontrollierte atomkraftwerk auch die
nahe gelegene hafenstadt nico pohl steht
unter dauerbeschuss anne brühl berichtet
es ist eine von 120 russischen raketen
die an diesem tag nico voll treffen tote
verletzte gibt es und menschen die unter
schock stehen
ich bin von einer gewaltigen explosion
wach geworden das war schrecklich ich
habe nur emotionen keine worte mehr
nicole ist im direkten fokus der russen
sie stehen nur vier kilometer entfernt
im atomkraftwerk von sapporo auf der
anderen flussseite
immer wieder kommt es dort zu
explosionen forst bevor am 6 juli gab es
vertreter der staatlichen russischen
rostow
aber sie haben die anlage kurz vor
beginn des angriffs verlassen doch sieht
ganz so aus als ob sie wussten dass der
beschuss beginn
sehr geschwätz war schlosser im
atomkraftwerk die russen sagt er hätten
versucht ihn umzubringen weil er nicht
kooperieren wollte er konnte fliehen
verfolgt die nachrichten mit sorge
alles ist möglich jeder hofft dass die
schutzsysteme arbeiten werden in nicole
befürchten sie eine katastrophe nicht
nur für die ukraine für ganz europa
ich weiß nicht ob es begründet ist aber
natürlich haben wir angst
dass wir sterben können und dass meine
mutter getötet wird das erschreckt mich
[Musik]
mit sorge blicken die menschen in nico
poll auf die andere seite des flusses
der schriftsteller seinen rushdie ist
bei einer veranstaltung im us staat new
york angegriffen worden rushdie wollte
gerade einen vortrag beginnen als ein
mann auf die bühne stürmte und auf ihn
einstach der 75 jährige autor wurde
schwer verletzt in eine klinik geflogen
wegen seines werks die satanischen verse
hatte irans oberster geistlicher
khomeini
1989 zu seiner tötung aufgefordert das
werk gilt vielen muslimen als
blasphemisch
bald ist es 50 jahre her das attentat
das
1972 die olympischen spiele in münchen
erschütterte elf israelische sportler
starben damals ihre hinterbliebenen
haben jetzt angekündigt die geplante
gedenkfeier im september zu boykottieren
sie fühlen sich von deutschland nicht
angemessen entschädigt stefan leifert
die friedhofsruhe erzählt nur die halbe
geschichte über das olympia attentat und
seine aufarbeitung
fünf der opfer sind hier in tel aviv
begraben einer davon fecht trainer
andere spitze seit 50 jahren kämpft
seine frau als sprecherin der
hinterbliebenen für aufklärung und
entschädigung der streit mit der
bundesregierung eskaliert nun
als uns klar wurde was die deutsche
seite als kompensation anbietet hielten
wir das für eine beleidigung
das kommt nicht annähernd in die höhe
dessen was internationalen standards
entspricht wir wären auch bereit das
minimum zu akzeptieren aber nicht
einfach ein trinkgeld
bei der geiselnahme durch
palästinensische terroristen und der
missglückten befreiungsaktion kamen in
münchen 1972 elf israelische sportler
ums leben nur zögerlich bekannte sich
deutschland zu seiner mitverantwortung
viereinhalb millionen euro entschädigung
flossen damals berlin bietet nun
fünfeinhalb weitere bleibt es dabei
wollen die hinterbliebenen der
gedenkfeier fern bleiben die
bundesregierung bedauert ist dass es bis
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht gelungen
ist auf dieser grundlage mit allen
hinterbliebenen zu einem konsens zu
kommen betont ausdrücklich ihre
bereitschaft zu weiteren gesprächen das
ist eine katastrophe mit ansage ich
halte es für beschämend wie mit den
berechtigten anliegen der opfer in den
letzten 50 jahren umgegangen wurde am
fliegerhorst fürstenfeldbruck findet am
5 september die gedenkfeier statt
israels präsident herzog will nur
teilnehmen wenn auch die hinterbliebenen
kommen bleiben noch drei wochen um den
eklat abzuwenden
im moment sind in münchen die european
championships modern und mit sehr
erfolgreichen deutschen bahnradfahrer
allerdings zweimal gold in zwei furiosen
finalrennen im team-sprint setzt sich
das deutsche trio gegen die niederlande
durch und so vor der große auftritt des
golf fahrers von tokio in der
mannschaftsverfolgung allen voran laura
brennauer die ihre großartige karriere
in münchen beenden wird voll fokussiert
und wie aus einem guss der deutsche
frauen vierer zu gold das finale in der
verfolgung über vier kilometer gegen
italien ein echter krimi auf rädern auf
dem nur 200 meter langen holzoval die
olympiasiegerinnen erst auf der
schlussrunde den entscheidenden dreh der
hauchdünne sieg in vier minuten 10 8 72
sekunden im letzten mannschaftsrennen
von lisa brenner
mein wunsch für dieses finale nochmals
machen und jetzt mit so einem titel nach
hause zu gehen ist einfach der wahnsinn
das quartett brennauer brauchste krüger
und klein mit dem ersten em gold für
deutschland und der zweite streich folgt
sogleich das weltmeister trio grabosch
hintze und friedrich last mit perfekten
wechseln und enormer power den
niederländerinnen im team-sprint davon
eine em titel premiere für die drei auf
der bahn in münchen legen die deutschen
frauen eine schwarz-rot-goldene
überholspur
ja und soeben gab es einen weiteren
deutschen erfolg laura lindemann gewann
silber im triathlon ja aber die erste
deutsche medaille bei diesen european
championships die gab es im bmx
freestyle wettbewerb der frauen und das
völlig überraschende stürze bei den
favoritinnen kindle müller aus oldenburg
die blieb cool und gewann silber
die erst 20-jährige überfliegerin ging
aufs ganze backflip three sixty kim lea
müller lieferte zwei mutige läufe in
diesem finale sie zeigte auch solche
kombinationen holte 78,60 punkte und
silber ich hab ich gar nicht damit
gerechnet ich habe mir einfach ein run
überlegt den ich machen wollte uns hat
geklappt die große favoritin
olympiasiegerin schalit wertingen
stürzte in beiden läufen die deutsche
medaillenhoffnung lara leßmann wurde
vierte überraschend gold gewann so die
tschechien wie wetter mit kulikowa vor
der strahlenden kim lea müller und der
französin julie peres
und der dritte wettkampftag der european
championships morgen live im zdf ab 9
uhr 45 frühauf schlossen ja genau
dankeschön ein zu wenig aus dem
italien-urlaub das kann eine muschel
sein oder pasta oder aber man baut sich
den vesuv zu hause nach mitsamt einer
insel drumrum einer villa und grotten so
hat es ende des achtzehnten jahrhunderts
fürst leopold der dritte friedrich franz
gemacht seine steingewordene
italiensehnsucht bei besser ist seit
heute frisch renoviert wieder zugänglich
und beim richtigen anlass kann der
vulkan dank licht und ton auch so tun
als bräche heraus
morgen im osten einzelne schauer und
gewitter sonst sonnig und weiter viel zu
trocken die details hat gleich christa
thoben das heute journal mit marietta
slomka um 10 unser gesamtes team wünscht
ihnen ein schönes wochenende
das morgen wenn sie mir wieder sehen
[Musik]
guten abend der helle vollmond wie hier
heute morgen über weddersleben
sachsen-anhalt erschwert im moment die
beobachtung der sternschnuppen der
perseiden die ihr leben ja heute nacht
ihren höhepunkt und meist spielt das
wetter auch mit es ist wolkenlos die
schauer- und gewitterwolken im südosten
des landes fallen jetzt auch schnell
wieder in sich zusammen denn insgesamt
haben wir im moment mit recht trockener
luft zu tun dadurch kann es auch gut
auskühlen südlich der donau auf 8 grad
nur an den küsten ist die nacht mild mit
18 grad hier speichert das küstennahe
wasser mit so 20 21 grad noch die wärme
morgen wird es dann wieder verbreitet
heiß am niederrhein mit bis 34 grad auch
in hamburg noch 32 grad nur im südosten
ist es mit 25 bis 29 grad etwas kühler
denn hier hin in den südosten und in den
osten transportiert morgen ein spürbarer
ostwind etwas feuchtere und schwüle luft
in der sich dann auch häufiger mal
quellwolken bilden nachmittag sind dann
auch einzelne schauer und gewitter mit
dabei ansonsten gibt es viel sonne
morgen und das ganze gilt auch für den
sonntag haben eine ganz ähnliche wetter
verteilung der montag der wird
interessanter kommt der wetterumschwung
mit wind aus südwest mit etwas mehr
wolken auch schauern und gewittern von
der regenmenge her kann dass die
trockenheit aber nicht lindern